well i
you know what i still gonna say magnus
is gonna edge it because magnus is the
king of comebacks he's showing us time
and time again that he's able to lose a
match and just continue as if nothing
else has happened and so i think that
he's the slight favorite but for rooja i
have to say i did check the stats of
last year's champions chess tour and he
has a better score against magnus on the
suit on the tour last season ah
interesting
magnus carlsen he is uh ready what will
be the first move from alireza of russia
talking to the arbiters maybe something
about the spectators but here we go here
we go it is a king's pawn opening as
predicted and ivanka is going to be very
happy with this one it's the karakon
defense yeah i suspected something like
this might happen
and uh well magnus is just simply
locking it down you know he's going to
go for a solid game i'm always very
surprised that magnus plays the kara
khan because i i remember in his streams
he kind of said was not necessarily an
opening that suits him that well and
here we have the two knights defense and
this move i have never seen before so
now i you've caught my attention magnus
what have you got up your sleeve do you
want to know a secret guys yep magnus
was playing the carican at the olympiad
and i think he wants to play this move i
think he had it prepared up his sleeve
um it's an idea of jordan van forest
one of his seconds of course during the
world championship match last year and
it does ask white the question how are
you going to
uh kind of move in the center white is
okay magnus is he smiling there
white cannot develop in the way that he
wants to white wants to throw pawns
forward in the center it's not possible
magnus definitely laughing he's just
happy he got in the first surprise and
already varuja is thinking on move three
move four wow um it's a weird move i'm
not sure it's a good move i looked at it
a bit myself a while ago i think white
has various ways to obtain an advantage
but they are not through normal means
okay and uh one of white's best moves
here is actually to move the white queen
bring the white queen out
magnus
really looking happy with himself yeah
proud
this queen sortie um yeah don't try this
at home guys
the black queen shouldn't really be
developing this early she might get
kicked around a bit later but uh it's
just the surprise effect the
psychological value here but is it
something jordan has played before or is
it a novelty for magnus uh jordan has
played it before um i checked this on
the database myself a while ago um i
think jordan has played this before in
blitz in rapid chess as well uh it's
very much uh in kind of a speed chess
speciality i think in a long game you
wouldn't play this necessarily because
uh with best play white obtains an
advantage but in rapid chess it might
cost farouja here five six minutes just
to kind of get out of the opening in a
situation he's happy with i think this
is the main idea behind the opening
black now is able to achieve a very
typical idea black's light squared
bishop out on an eye square and white
knight cannot jump into the center
neither the white knights can jump into
the middle of the board because actually
the black queen covers some key squares
yeah yeah um i have to say you know as
someone who
played the scandinavian a lot when i was
younger and also the caracal now this
looks like a great hybrid um
white hasn't jumped forward and put
pressure on black's position and if
black is just allowed to continue just
develop the knight get the dart square
bishop out
he's
well he stands
really really well
got the dream carrot position
yeah black will be very solid it will be
hard for white to create anything i'm
expecting fruit at some point to start
pushing some pawns uh in the center
there we go
and yeah magnus is going to just put up
this wall of pawns he's going to say
okay white can do what he wants on his
first four ranks but uh stepping forward
any further will be difficult i don't
like it
i'm just
i mean i think ivanka it's that
and scandinavian experience is going to
magnus is laughing to himself now
really surprising i mean we see this
when he sits at home in regulars but in
the arena i've never seen this public
with dozens
in the arena oh the spectator is getting
value for their money i'm guessing maybe
someone told him something very funny
along the way to the venue because you
know i you know i had a very interesting
chat with
his father henrik carlson and he was
saying that they actually make an effort
and prepare to put magnus in a good mood
because magnus in a good mood place
fantastic chess okay so this is a good
sign for the magnus fans i think so it
means he's relaxed he's not tense and
he's just going to be enjoying himself
now uh here we have ali reza he's
actually gone
hunting the light square bishop he wants
to trade a knight for the bishop and
normally black isn't that bothered to be
honest yes you know white will get the
bishop pair but instead the focus will
be
on just developing the pieces and later
on in the game putting pressure on the
semi-open line
the d-line
i can tell in your voice ivanka you love
this for black yeah and i also i i found
his humor a bit contagious because i
just started laughing as well just
because he was laughing we should
mention though there is a big trend that
when magnus starts laughing he ends up
blundering or losing games and also when
magnus has the karakan as you mentioned
um his score is actually not great it's
far kind of inferior to his score in the
e4 e5 types of openings and in the
sicilian defense magnus has lost some
key games his unbeaten streak against
duda ended when he played the kara khan
in the olympiad he drew with black hair
against the lower rated player with the
karakan defense i remember several
losses actually for magnus
throughout the tour and other events so
he tends to obtain a decent position
here it's solid enough but uh does it
suit his style and simon you mentioned
you'd prefer white why's that
um well i certainly prefer white a
couple moves ago and just because i was
looking at black's development i mean
look at black's king
it's going to take black free moves to
get castled um you've got a knight and
the bishop in the way you don't want to
castle queen side in these positions i i
wouldn't have thought
and i you know for me with the white
king castle that's like a bit of a red
rag it's like okay i would have been
very tempted to push the b porn up two
squares earlier on something like this
you know play play something a bit more
aggressive to try and take a take
advantage of the fact that black is very
badly developed
um now though after knight h4 i have to
say i i don't think black has any
problems um black's going to get rid of
this so-called bad light square bishop
we saw this was a theme yesterday if
that bishop was back on its
original square it'd be a tremendously
bad piece because it's caged in but now
you're gonna get rid of that um so i
think you know i'm wondering if white's
gonna try pushing freddy the f porn but
black can stop that idea immediately by
attacking the knights just moved but
yeah i mean i have to say now it looks
fine to me black's got the typical
carrot card set up and if you're playing
the caracane you've got to be happy with
this position uh i just think maybe
white earlier on could have done
something a little bit more aggressive
potentially
and this is an interesting bishop move
from magnus carlsen because the idea
that you mentioned simon of pushing the
f pawn just to kind of destabilize
harass the light square bishop it is a
common theme and often
where you can you kind of want to
develop your knight to the e7 square
just to
control that uh f5 square
much more
yeah black is rock solid and it's going
to be hard to achieve this push it's
going to be extremely hard to achieve
this push therefore white maybe has to
slow down the pace of the game
and just maneuver and yeah this pawn
push is very committal i remember
mikhail tal doing this a few times as
white and getting really dodgy positions
but making it work instead ferruccio
goes with maybe the more traditional way
of pushing pawns and he gains a bit of
space here hinting that he might try and
explode open the center
at some point ivanka i think he'll write
us uh black might choose this square for
the black knight the reason foruger
doesn't rush and probably won't rush in
the near future by taking this bishop
it's because suddenly black's rook
and black's bishop both point down in
this direction it looks a bit scary now
for the white king
so i think he'll delay this capture as
long as possible he'll try and only
capture here once the black king has
castled on this side
we'll see a waiting game now both sides
just trying to put their pieces on good
squares magnus uh has started a little
bit of think
no
moving his queen back
on developing pieces i mean
yeah don't try this at home i've got to
say it again because uh he's breaking
all the rules magnus he's hitting this
knight he's trying to force a capture of
his bishop because as mentioned this
would open up the rook maybe the queen
actually wants to jump out now and
magnus wants to deliver some really
basic checkmate david sorry i i have
cheated because i was wondering why the
evaluation bar's gone up massively in
frozen's favor and there's a tremendous
move here a tremendous move which is
actually very logical considering the
underdevelopment and the amount of time
that black has simply wasted here just
to blast over yeah
because this is the most thematic
definitely
i reckon this is totally a farouza move
as well he loves attacking this move
could cause a lot of problems for magnus
according to the engine um because
black's king is in the middle this has
been a danger and you're you're going to
get your piece back this way so yeah
sorry but just this had to be mentioned
it's such a dangerous move yeah and
there we see uh simon stockfish the
computer does confirm that this is by
far the best move retreating the white
knight for example uh even capturing the
bishop or stepping back those are decent
too but this is the strongest and you
mentioned white will gain the piece back
you're giving your knight away on the
edge of the board for free but after a
capture i'm guessing this way suddenly
white's queen is the one unleashed
against this bishop and you have a
threat against the black knight so one
of those two pieces would drop for
example pawn takes pawn and the white
queen jumps in and uh yeah black's
position is just in ruins the king's
stuck in the middle uh so will ferrugia
find this really really strong idea he
doesn't but he might uh combine this
idea and now perhaps yeah
just try to blast open the center you
could still try i guess maybe slightly
less effective now because uh there
could be a trade at the very least black
can block it up you still have to worry
about the queen coming in he has played
this however we are going to see
fireworks
russia on the attack already all right
the action has started inside the arena
but tanya we're also very excited to
meet some of the spectators that have
taken the trip to miami to follow these
top players
absolutely as the fireworks are on over
the board we can feel it with our
spectators there's a lot of discussion
going on and they're whispering to each
other uh because we can see it is
getting hot on the boards well there's
one family that's driven five hours to
come and watch their favorite players in
action
and let's find out what it's like to be
here hey guys hi how are you i'm good
all right tell us a little bit about uh
you and you play chess yeah so i've been
playing for seven years so i first
figured out my passion for the game when
i was six in school where we had a
tournament well i did pretty good and
then i saw that maybe i do have like the
talent for this game wow
and ania what about you are you excited
to be here i'm super excited i've been
watching magnus carlson's game and when
i started watching them and started
going to tournaments i actually started
getting at least five or six points
and i started playing six months ago
watching my brother play that's so cool
and what's it like to actually see them
live in action here
super exciting
i love it so safe to say you guys are
rooting for magnus oh yes
all right well enjoy the games it's
getting pretty intense in there as you
can see everyone from across the country
is here to enjoy the chess back to you
guys
ah we love it tanya thank you so much so
cool to see everyone traveling
to miami to see these players and of
course we also love everyone around the
world watching this from at home
absolutely we really love having your
support and the players do as well so
today for our selfie competition we are
asking how are you cheering for your
favorite player do you have your phone
fingers do you have some special hats
special
signs could be anything
well anyway we want to see we want you
to show us as always you can tweet your
selfies using the hashtag chessjams and
one winner will get one year's chess 24
premium membership
so look forward to seeing who are you
cheering for and show us how i'm
thinking also like chats like you would
have in the football soccer arena oh my
god songs for the favorite players can
you guys come up with some cool
you know magnus carlsen or from songs
our viewers are just incredible i mean
they really just completely blow me away
with their ingenuity so i can't wait to
see what they're going to come up with i
reckon there will be rhymes there will
be songs there will be signs
there will be big foam fingers
something to have magnus carlsen smile
he is smiling still magnus carlsen he's
having a lot of fun in the start of this
game
but
the bar is not overly excited about his
position on the board
does it have anything to do with the
game david that he's smiling or do you
think it's something complete yes um who
knows at this point i don't think i've
ever seen magnus this happy and uh i
don't think it's the position the
position is still complicated enough
to make black sweat a bit especially
while as simon mentioned that black king
is a massive target in the center
maybe it's to do with the music he's
listening to or something connected with
this opening we have seen magnus kind of
freestyle with some weird wacky openings
in the past and it tends to kind of get
him in a good mood
so i have a feeling it's more to do with
the opening or the music rather than the
current position on the board but uh
what do you guys think it does look a
bit scary still for black it does yeah i
mean
my initial thought is what if black goes
to checkmate so maybe we can show this
lie because it's the most forcing
i don't think it works out very well but
um we can share so you could as black
try to use the placement of the rook and
throw the queen in
and this threatens checkmate um there's
only really one decent way of stopping
that you've got to move the pawn and now
it might be oh can black winner win a
pawn here uh but this is going to
backfire massively
and if black tries to win a pawn i think
he's going to get his queen trapped uh
at the end of it uh so there's there's
like little tricks here and this just
shows that black at the moment can't go
on the offensive if you know this bishop
move here just trapping the queen the
queen has no squares to go to so it's
it's more like
there are some quite big issues to solve
in the center of the board for magnus i
mean uh i'm sure there's a way to do it
but it's very unpleasant
i would be very unhappy here trying to i
wouldn't be smiling as much as magnus i
feel uh trying to trying to just work
out how do i get my king safe because uh
that that is numero problem
actually problem number one okay threw
the queen in
um and maybe that's all right on its own
that's certainly probably not a terrible
move but you don't want to take the
knight next move is it you can't cast
the queen sides i'm just really
interested to know how is he going to
stop these issues yeah at the moment i
i'm not entirely sure i mean david
mentioned trying to close down the
center is that the way to do it that be
the normal way to try and play try to
close the area of the ball where you're
getting the tack down he's actually
captured with the other pawn
okay interesting so he's taken with the
pawn and he has blocked it um maybe he
just wants to keep his bishop open on
this diagonal um it felt a bit loose
somehow
but i guess the reason he put his queen
on this square is that the white knight
can no longer kind of go and um kick
away the blockader of white's past pawn
in the middle of the board now as long
as black gets kind of two moves if black
can get his knight out and castle
probably on the king's side
he'll be happy
it's just about whether furuja gives him
that uh
that time that luxury yeah and uh the
thing is he has to put the k the knight
on that particular square because uh so
if you put it say for instance on the e7
square i know it's white to play the
bishop will actually come out to
b5 and pin the knight and say well you
know
king he's going to stay in there maybe
you could maybe you can do that anyway
you think i mean that that looks like
the logical move to me with a check
coming up next i don't see how black's
gonna easily get castled after that
bishop comes to that square and i think
it is you know you've got to be quite
aggressive here with the white pieces
because
david you pointed out if black castles
he's fine he's got a blockade on in in
the position so you want to try to play
very aggressively here as white i think
stop that casting at least uh
discombobulate black a little bit
in the position i mean if black is
forced to for example meet a check with
just a king move then at least these two
rooks will never be connected they'll
never join up and the black king will
always feel a bit uncomfortable likewise
uh i like this move simon just because
you're kind of trying to ask black to
castle on the other side of the board
but here it's much more open the black
king there are kind of squares around it
it's a bit airy um you could definitely
imagine white kind of pushing pawns
later to explode open lines uh towards
this piece and
yeah
that looks
natural that looks strong
very logical as well just trying to go
for this black king while there's an
opportunity but he needs to be quick for
rujo he can't let uh he just can't play
slowly and let the black king castle
this side to safety then i think magnus
will start doing magnus things and
kind of start
out playing his opponent simply because
this pawn will become more of a weakness
than a strength if black's king gets to
safety look at that it's packed inside
the miami arena the spectators sitting
only a few meters away from the players
fighting in the tournament do you think
they're noticing them simon
i'm i i doubt it in some way because
they're kind of like really focused you
get in the zone when you're playing i
mean all these guys we've got remember
they are used to playing with big crowds
they just come from the olympiad in in
india where you where you i mean david
and ivanka you were there but you you
said it took you half an hour to get to
the board because there's so many people
so it's like they they're used to having
a crowd there and you kind of you know
you zone out a little bit for the people
there i love the idea that ivanka
mentioned earlier of giving the crowd
the headset so you can hear because they
had that once in the 93 world
championships caspara versus nigel short
i remember i was there and they had to
actually stop the commentary because
they were cracking so many jokes that
the crowd would just all of a sudden
start laughing and nigel would be like
they're not they're laughing at my move
you know what's going on and like you
know because of the commentary but um
okay we have another move uh on the
board now which seems very slow but it's
maybe getting the rook around i guess
yeah really interesting uh white's rook
in the corner
would have taken kind of ages otherwise
to activate it it's just going to slide
up two squares and maybe swing across
somewhere as you mentioned simon it's
slow and maybe black's king can now
kind of hurry away to safety on that
side of the board
so yeah i'm expecting magnus without too
much thought to bring his night out the
night that's not developed
and castle with haste
yeah i mean that move it
is slightly slow it just doesn't feel
like it hits the nail on the head it
feels like the action should have been
taking place in the center
but uh okay we can't be too critical it
doesn't worsen white's position at all
one thing black shouldn't be tempted to
do is what you said a couple of moves
like go simon take that white knight
with the black bishop black's bishop is
actually the key piece sitting in front
of white's pawn in the middle he's got
to be a blockader
and uh okay magnus thinking however yeah
maybe magnus was taken
by surprise by that move because we
weren't expecting it didn't seem to us
the most logical move which was to
introduce pieces into the attack still
he's like i'm laughing away
i mean with that hair he reminds me of
john travolta in greece what's that
going forwards who's latino yeah people
have mentioned him and neiman might have
the same hairdresser
i don't know
[Music]
do you think they have that much hair
he is uh fighting today against levon
aronian it's a prestigious one
all-american against lavon ironian
playing in miami
levon must be said to be a big favorite
tons neyman's still on zero points in
the tournament but he has given us a lot
of entertainment and he has had some
great moments he did win a game against
magnus carlsen magnus actually has lost
a few of the first round games this
tournament is this a big chance for
alireza in that first game when magnus
is maybe a little out of focus in the
start of the day yeah there is this
saying that magnus starts slow he always
finishes high he always when he needs to
he tends to win but in these first games
maybe just kind of getting into the zone
takes a while for uh for magnus
and uh yeah i think this first game is
key if russia takes the lead i think
we're gonna have a really dramatic match
uh ivanka you've spotted something no i
haven't suppose i was looking at magnus
is like laughing why is he laughing
somewhere i mean
like some kind of dance is definitely
listening to
some kind of i don't know but he's
digging whatever he's listening to and i
i like it
and uh chill vibe in miami today
definitely yeah i mean these are cool
dudes and uh you know
on the subject of uh chanting you kind
of asked kaya whether our viewers could
come up with chance well swapnil valvey
says that here's a chant for prague
chess
we've got the king prague i just don't
think you understand he's a south indian
pal he's better than tao
we've got the king bag i like it yeah i
kind of
had to take a breath though that wasn't
my problem that's why i poured it
very nice presentation of that yeah
not bad at all he's good at chanting the
english rose rapper ivanka husker well
so
i think i think we should you know get a
little chess album out anyone else think
that ivanka ivanka's wraps
yeah
yeah
i need to get my breath work because you
know it kind of you've got to get the
momentum going because i thought you
have to go
and then yeah
i think
every player in this tournament all
later than they deserve at least one
chant today i think that should be the
goal for the spectators out there our
viewers
try and come up with a chant for each
player yeah i'd love to hear one for
hands wouldn't you i mean like you know
hans has been a bit of the you know star
away from the board isn't he so what who
can make a good chance for him
david immediately start thinking about
it
yeah quite a lot you know so yeah
well you can't wait to see what the
viewers come up with but meanwhile what
an ugly move by magnus
um
okay maybe it's not so bad the computer
doesn't like it either but he's giving
away all the light squares on this left
side of the board he's stopping white
from advancing further with uh his flank
pawn uh his a pawn so he's blocking
things up magnus loves to do that he
hates his opponents gaining space on the
side of the board but he's yeah giving
away the light squares when you have no
light squared bishop
so that's my first instinct at least
he's still laughing magnus what's going
on today i'm not focused no not at all
is he listening to a podcast or saying
that's really i mean like but that last
move to my eyes looks disgusting
yeah i mean
because we wanted to move the bishop
nick and yeah here the bishop can now
sit there forever
uh it's even better now because the
other rook i
i mean he did some very peculiar things
yesterday
some of the moves from the world
champion uh in this tournament
yesterday and today are shocking me more
than i've ever seen
in any other tournament he's played uh i
just that move just looks so ugly to me
what am i missing what am i missing guys
i mean am i missing something i don't
see it either he must have been really
scared of white pushing maybe his uh if
we show this on the analysis board um i
guess the only explanation for magnus's
kind of pawn push here is that if he had
developed he was afraid of white
stepping forward the black king castling
and maybe the white rook stepping up to
kick away the queen and the queen
actually lacking squares the queen's
only safe square is actually in the
corner or one of these two squares not
ideal so maybe this was uh what scared
magnus this kind of rook swinging across
the board so
in that regard perhaps uh this is
something that he wants to avoid but as
you say simon after this pawn push black
doing the same uh we do have a couple
more moves but this is an eternal
outpost white bishop will love life on
this square for the rest of the game uh
pinning down on this diagonal and
wow i mean
you mentioned shocking moves magnus is
just planted as king in the middle of
the board
i mean this is a bit of an odd scenario
at the best of times but if white can
somehow magic his pawn off the board
then suddenly the black king is just
going to be toast in the center
white lifting his rook up now very
logical from ferrugia maybe aiming to
kind of swing across and start attacking
stuff uh defending his knight across the
board as well but uh after the white
knight comes out we see an offer of a
trade from magnus and the rooks do leave
the board
i'm expecting now magnus to kind of
change his mind take with the king and
start running this way
and uh there we go magnus's king has
done some serious exercise in the last
few moves
but long term he's still in trouble
white has a past pawn white has a bind
on the light squares on the queen side
what is magnus going to do he just has
to tuck his king away and hope for the
best yeah i have to say it does i mean
i feel like and and i'm going to quote
a character from catherine tate nan
someone has taken liberties
and
i mean he's just moved his king
twice he's moved his queen like one two
three three times and then
i i just i just feel you can't play
chess like that you can't just get the
rule book rip it up
burn it
there's they're there for a reason
big threat i guess on the board white's
rook wants to do the same uh kind of
threat against the black queen if the
black king moves now this is a matter of
urgency it needs to run away then
suddenly where's your queen going uh
magnus you don't really want to put your
king your queen kind of on a passive
square in the corner of the board no
queen wants to be sitting on the corner
uh if you put it here still no active
squares to come
black could be playing without a queen i
mean there's going to be ideas of white
bishop coming out white's rook swinging
across trying to trap this queen
it looks terrifying now for magnus
carlsen he's got two problem pieces and
as you may mentioned these problem
pieces have moved already several times
look at his time
look at the time as well is this right
away again with his king
i mean this is just shock a minute stuff
uh white's rook now forcing the black
queen into the corner
have you ever seen a worse queen have
you ever seen a misplaced king
if black survives this if magnus
survives this game it's going to be a
miracle david can we just like do the
the journey of this queen like it
started to go it went to a5
and then it went back and then it went
all over to h4
and then it's gone back and now it's
probably gonna end up on e8 where the
king and the queen have kind of switched
places i haven't i haven't really seen
that before
yeah this is uh maybe what magnus is
laughing about he sees that he's
actually gonna
for example
let's say white just plays around a move
if he puts his queen on this square he
is actually going to have swapped around
his king and queen
how often do you see this in chess it's
kind of a troll type of opening to play
this in blitz games bullet games but
magnus has done it the long way round
he swapped those guys uh swap those
pieces
i have no idea what he's doing
creatively but playing with uh playing
with fire it just seems
kind of like i just don't understand
this game i really i really don't
understand it i mean this idea of the
rook coming up i have to say i've missed
uh you know with with ali razor's idea
of pushing the the pawn on the side of
the board it's a really good idea that
you pointed out there david but
this this is just so ugly putting your
queen in the corner putting your king
somewhere moving it around i i i don't
understand it at all and white's moves
are very natural white is just making
normal good moves he's got some great
squares for his bishop pair he's got the
long-term advantage of his this pawn in
the middle um and all of his pieces look
very very nice the knight might better
jump in yeah is knight's going to jump
in next move probably i mean it kind of
looks like it should
maybe be losing [ __ ]
for for black simply just losing yeah it
feels like if magnus survives
for five more moves
it will be a miracle i mean where's the
queen go now you can't even move it to
the to the troll square um i mean it
can't even go there and it's covered and
white's gonna just look at this the
knight comes in you're gonna win at
least the bishop pair with a great
position i i i
i mean taking that bishop is a major
threat it's actually threatening to win
the game
uh immediately i feel and i i don't yeah
like say you think i don't think magnus
is going to last and this is only move
like what is it move 24 24 i mean yes he
has to move 30 yeah i think he'll have
to thank the chess guards for magnus wow
doesn't really deserve to the way he's
been playing unfortunately i mean jordan
found forester's queen a5 can we blame
it on that move no i don't think we can
blame it on that because i think the
position he got was okay we can blame it
on the queen retreating i mean he could
have just done normal stuff which was
just develop the pieces get the king to
safety
that's how the classical way of playing
chess this way was just
weird he's running the whole way across
the board with his king he wants to keep
heading across he maybe wants to move
the king across one square and plant it
in front of his room can't even do that
can he because you're going to lose your
queen
i mean you can't where's that king going
you can't put the king on a dart square
because you lose your queen or lose the
piece i mean yeah i don't understand
well
this is really one of the most
bewildering i can't even say the word
now the wilderness that i've seen and
it's so weird to see magnus smiling as
well he's usually very critical okay
there we have it
now he's not happy that's the first
shake of the head we've seen today from
magnus and it won't be the last shake of
the head in this game
because it's just all gone wrong all
white needs to do
is i i mean i like your idea simon at
some point in the next move or two trade
off black's bishop black's bishop is the
only thing holding
the position together trade that one off
for white tonight bring the white queen
into the attack
at some point there will be some deadly
checks against the black king black is
playing without his rook
i mean
the problem for farouza here is that
there's too many tempting moves you
could capture the black knight you can
capture the black bishop you can just
bring the white queen out immediately
i think you've choose i think
everything's winning yeah i honestly
just think nearly any move here is
winning for white and it's as simple as
that because white takes the time out
and just kind of shuffles the white king
somewhere pointlessly he's probably
still winning yeah i mean i i was just
tempted by capturing the knights
and then winner pawn
put the rook on the bottom row you know
there's going to be a check with the
queen on the light square i just
don't
know
i mean she doesn't actually have any
squares i don't know what his next move
is either late night takes nights come
first simple
yeah and now you can win the queen for a
bishop and brooke if you want to
he's gonna have to go for that right
let's show this on the board that's a
few moves there um
so white did indeed win a pawn on the f6
square and
as you guys are advocating the queen is
now actually trapped after moving what
is it five six times this black queen
she's trapped on her own back rank
nowhere to run to um you have to give
her up just for a rook and bishop which
isn't sufficient compensation um here
you have some kind of blockade at least
with these pieces uh they're kind of at
least on stable squares on dark squares
right now but as soon as the white queen
joins the action
this is just going to be game over how
are you going to hold these pawns
together long term eventually as well
white has a three versus two advantage
on this side of the board one of the
white pawns will become past later on
and if you look at the kind of current
position as well black's queen has kind
of spent what was it yeah around six
moves uh this game so far white's queen
hasn't moved at all but white's queen is
still better than the black queen
white's queen is still more flexible so
basically white has used those extra six
moves that black has wasted uh really
productively also
how many times has the black king moved
one two three four five times i mean you
don't even need to win the queen
immediately do you i mean you can do
that as well you know
that rook move is is not going anywhere
because black can't really move anything
there's no squares for the black pieces
white's bishop dominates you can maybe
bring your queen out first i mean uh
this is honestly one of the weirdest
games i've seen in my time commentating
here on tour um everyone has a bad day
everyone has a bad game so i i guess we
can put it down to that really uh you
know everyone it happens to everyone and
it's strange with all the the smiling
and the laughing and yeah it is not
concentrated at all yeah
that's straight that is what makes it
even weirder right i mean he's laughing
his way into a terrible boss
so um i i you know and maybe it's an
embarrassment thing now that you know
he was smiling long before he had a lost
position though yeah yeah
and he's still
he's still grinning so what's going on
then guys why why why because i mean
this is so unlikely magnus carlsen right
yeah i mean like you said simon everyone
has one bad day you can't help it we
thought that day was yesterday for
magnus where he was just making these
uncharacteristic one-move blunders but
to start today
in a similar fashion it's not even one
with blunders it's just
plain bizarre decisions that are almost
inexplicable yeah
and the only reason for magnus carlsen
to smile right now is that it looks like
young christoph duda is winning game one
against pragnan under the bar all the
way over to his side now we have some
waving
hi i wish they could see us waving back
oh that's cool they're waving to the
camera it's a full house in the miami
arena with spectators coming from all
over the u.s to watch the top chess
players in action maybe disappointed
right now magnus carlsen is not playing
a good first game against dolly reza for
russia and the one who has a really big
reason to have a big smile now is
hollywood sofarucha because uh
well if prague loses as much and magnus
loses as much to others of russia than
he will be in the lead
the frenchman with uh one day to go
we're getting a great start to the day
drama-wise yeah huge drama and that
would be almost decisive i mean for
russia he's already played his two big
rarifiers he's already played prague
today he will have played magnus so if
he wins today's match
he's got it all in his own hands yeah
and okay now black's queen attacks the
white rook
again magnus just wants to give up his
queen he's just saying take my queen
it's trapped
white's rook can just step one square up
the board
and that whole kind of exchange that
transition will happen here we go
the black queen is lost and after the
black queen disappeared white's queen
has gone to winner pawn
this one is just uh a matter of
technique now it should be relatively
straightforward for ferugia
uh white's queen just needs to move out
the waist at some point uh that black
knight is pinned tied down black's
bishop is fixed on its square pretty
much black's rook is active at least
that's the one positive for magnus for
the world champion right now credit to
ferruga he's kind of played really
smoothly he hasn't been disturbed by his
opponents
really surprising moves sometimes when
your opponent plays a bit provocatively
you get really disturbed
and the white queen comes back your
anchor you were yeah i was kind of
hoping that uh ferugia might play in a
fast flashy way with the bishop coming
to the c6 square but that would have
been a bit
much maybe
once queen changes direction instead
maybe trying to go all the way up to the
top of the board
uh there are entry squares in black's
camp
you can't keep the white queen out
forever no you can't all classes don't
exist in this position i mean the one
thing that faruja has to be careful of
is that simply you know that the white
king could be potentially vulnerable to
a backrank checkmate
but that's something that's pretty
elementary and uh farouja will not be so
careless to allow such a thing like that
i don't know i wouldn't pull it out the
way this game's going
i mean
i'm not sure i'm watching these two
players if i'm watching their game you
know
primary school if we didn't know the two
players
simon if you just if someone submitted
that or she showed you the moves yes you
would say i mean you so you would say
like yeah white white's playing good
natural moves but black's played some
really strange you know you you honestly
would wouldn't you i mean
you'd probably say
eighteen hundred maybe not twenty eight
hundred
not even eighteen hundred harsh yeah i i
mean this whole queen journey is just so
atypical because
most players know you know you've got to
develop your pieces but like simon says
everybody has an off day where somehow
you think you can be creative and you
think you can but you're still laughing
what's going on i don't know i get it i
mean i can't explain it simon does he
just want to give himself a challenge
just kind of throw away the first game
and come back like he did yesterday
against duda uh he was two points down
yesterday against duda i don't know he
has it's a bit unlike magnus i i say
it's a bit it's really unlike magnus
exactly and now black's rook is asked a
question black's root can actually take
the pawn uh in front of it white's h
pawn so the black rook
could get greedy but it would end up on
a really bad square and white queen is
ready to come up to the top of the board
and start attacking the black knight
attacking some pawns i think that would
be disastrous almost
magnus i think he's more likely to bring
the black rook somewhere on the fourth
rank just to activate it
or bring it back this does stop at least
white's queen entering the position but
i mean if we do a quick material count
white has a queen and two pawns black
only has a rook and knight in return so
queen in two pawns that's worth 11
points rook and knight worth eight
uh plus three on the counter in terms of
material now the white queen this is how
versatile she is she just checks forces
the black knight back to a bad square
hits the rook in the corner now the
black king is the target now the queen's
going to come in and start taking those
king side pawns i mean dropping it's
completely over it has been for a while
i mean it's just like trying to pull up
maybe trying to plan the game to uh move
30. i is the only thing i think and okay
that's it basically yeah
it's over magnus carlsen he loses game
one playing a horrible game here
the world number one
and laughing while doing it it's very
strange but holy rezabruja he takes the
lead in this very crucial match in the
ftx crypto cup i'm very curious to see
if we will see reactions in miami
especially from magnus it would be nice
to hear what this was all about
nope
he uh
yeah we will have a reaction let's go to
miami what was it about oh you played
well uh it was a good game man
gotta do better
huh
this is very strange you guys
what is magnus crossing up to
it's just hard to explain yeah i'm
speechless to be honest he seems in a
good mood still um he's still capable of
fighting back of course he's got white
next farouza is notoriously good with
white as we mentioned earlier so a loss
might have happened anyway but that
style of loss
he's just boosted faroush's confidence
as well it's uh surprising stuff yeah i
i mean i suppose you know frugia did
play very well
but his moves
you know weren't particularly hard to
find in the middle game uh he did this
rook's pawn we'll talk about but i don't
know i suppose we if we think about
magnus in that game like and we talk
about it it's like okay he played like a
series of three or four bad moves um and
then he was kind of hopeless situation
but
it just it was very bizarre very bizarre
game so and you guys were not a big fan
of the game so we'll just keep analyzing
it uh we don't want to learn from that
game i guess but this one is also so
important you guys for the tournament
situation pragnanda
first game against young christoph duda
and is duda winning this game one it's
looking good for duda if we do a quick
count both sides have the same number of
pieces but black has an extra pawn and
it's not just going to be one point it's
going to be a second extra pawn incoming
um white's pawn on the c file there
is going to drop to the black rook or
the black knight and two point advantage
here it looks pretty much decisive there
we go it's two pawns up now for duda
white's bishop is not participating in
the battle
the black knight looks very good right
now black's pawns are perfectly placed
black's king brook active
it's all stacking up in the polish
players favor i think pragnando the only
chance of saving this game is to somehow
get his work active win a pawn back
but uh yeah he's reliant now prague on
some serious blunders from duda and you
can tell on his body language he's
uh he's distraught a more normal game
this one but just looks like uh
the older player here in in duda in this
case has outplayed his young opponent
yeah and
i think
we are looking at the end because
max knight is probably going to dive in
to the d3 square and start attacking
some pawns
and there's just really not that much
that prague can do to stop any of this
and he gives a check
king is probably going to take a step
back attack the rook
that's what we call a spike check it
doesn't really help the position it's
just you want to throw in one check
before you resign
and uh the black king defends all its
bournes gains time against the white
rook
yeah black's about to win a third born
when that white rook moves
and therefore pragnanda gives up he
resigns and duda takes the win wow he
lost his match yesterday pragnanda and a
horrible start
to today he is one of the players
fighting to win the tournament but a
great win for young christophe duda he
started out with a win against magnus
carlsen as well yes